you mean i'll kiss your bride
she's so beautiful i love her i'll even
marry her even in my next life oh
as people would say where i'm from
kobe got game
colby on the farm away i'm just playing
you can tell he really means it
damn he's sweet
he's the nicest guy i've ever been with
like as you can see kobe and emily are
officially husband and wife so you know
what that means
it's really heavy on me i can continue
living in your father's house looking at
it
yep after keeping it a secret for weeks
they finally tell her parents they're
expecting baby number two after
promising them they wouldn't have any
more kids while living under their roof
oh my god all right
we'll get into her dad's interesting
reaction
as well as what had kobe breaking down
in tears ahead of the ceremony plus
[Music]
we're going to take a look at the
standout moments from the other weddings
this episode including shaida and
bilal's
also patrick and thyee
hold on
can somebody tell me why patrick and
thyes officiant is looking too cool for
school with these sunglasses and gucci
jacket on during the ceremony
i've never seen anything like that
and look i'm all for being yourself but
the picture sir did you think about the
pictures
you may kiss the bride
let's get into it
hey money day fans fam it's melicia
[Music]
yeah i know that's a breakup song but
the point is
we're at the end this is the final
episode before the tell-all and every
couple has managed to say i do
which isn't always the case last week
ari and benny got married as did eve and
muhammad now let's get into kobe and
emily's big day oh i'm also talking to
emily soon so drop any questions you
have for her in the comments and i'll
pick a few keep in mind that she might
not be able to answer certain questions
because of restrictions but i'll get to
as many as i can alright back to the
episode i feel bad that i just came at
you the way that i did morning of their
wedding emily apologizes to kobe for
questioning his intentions the night
before at that rehearsal dinner
in reality this is a man from
cameroon who i met in china if you can't
trust me at the eve of our wedding
a moment that led to him storming off on
her i'm sorry i really do trust you
and i know you have sacrificed so much
to be here with cobin and i
and i really cannot wait to marry you oh
well no surprise here they make up
i love you just put out of the back of
your mind
i love you
but you know this whole emily
questioning kobe's intentions had me
thinking
how sometimes when you're so used to
disappointment you'll find all types of
reasons to question something good when
it enters your life you know we're so
close to getting married and she has
trust issues
they're not like necessarily towards you
they're just like in general
now we know that kobe is not perfect but
emily's admitted that he's the sweetest
guy she's ever been with
deep down she might think he seems too
good to be true
i was telling myself the other day how
it's wild that we can be hoping and
asking for something better and then the
moment it comes we have a hard time
accepting it
accepting that nothing has to be wrong
that this is the better you've been
asking for
you know
it's like you think you deserve good
things right so
act like it all right
let me get off my soapbox all right i
love you
guys bye
fast forward to when they start to get
ready for the ceremony emily has an
emotional moment with her mom after she
puts on her gown i know i haven't been
the easiest on my parents
they've been there for all my rough
relationships all the mistakes i've made
[Music]
so like today i don't know just seeing
my mom
look at me in my dress like it means a
lot because i know
she's really proud of me and
like it means the world to me that my
mom approves of kobe and she wants the
best for us
oh
that's the mama hugging her baby type
hugs
meanwhile kobe
wow
this man is out here showing all of his
goodies while he gets dressed for the
wedding i mean goodness
a total zaddy huh
he's a married man what does that have
to do with me i am not about to sit here
and go back and forth with clips i'm so
nervous like don't be divorced man as
you can see kobe's friend from cameroon
who now lives in texas is there and so
is his best man tim aka temperature and
yes he is still piping hot i've got
people
um the greatest four years since that
time
the wedding should have go through
successfully but i believe with time
could be most understand that he's a man
and in africa
we call the shot okay temp we get it
emily's dad shows up for some moral
support and to give kobe a gift
very handsome thanks so much sir yeah
and the moment they share
in my opinion proves how much of a
stand-up human being mr david is he has
a big heart and so does kobe i had a lot
of serious doubts before kobe came to
america
but
he sent me a letter
telling me how much he loved emily and
that you know he wanted my permission to
marry her
and i wrote him a letter back saying
it's important for him now to step up to
the plate and take care of things
well you remember the first uh letter
you sent me with yeah
asking permission yeah
yeah you remember my response i remember
i remember everything so sometimes i go
through here i'm gonna give you this for
the life of me i've been trying to
figure out what mr david put in kobe's
hand
was it money was it a key if so a key to
what
i don't know unfortunately we never find
out what he gave to kobe but whatever it
was
this moment leads to both of them crying
in each other's arms
thank you so much
[Music]
yeah i'm
well
it's your job now
so
that's for you
emily and copen you know you take charge
and
you've got to head them in the right
direction
[Music]
let's
go prefer someone
all right man
all right i love you like a son
this was one of the most heartwarming
moments
i've seen all season
so
it's gonna be a good day once the tears
start flowing for kobe it's hard for him
to stop i gave kobe something personal
that i wanted him to have that would
remind him of what my letter said to him
it's a really beautiful thing oh don't
you love a man who is not afraid to cry
it is beautiful
kobe goes on to reveal why this moment
is so special for
him don't jump in my heart i really do
appreciate everything that you've done
not only for me
you know
raising my son
i knocked off your daughter back in
china
you accepted me in your house you know i
traveled all the way from africa i
didn't know where i was going to stay
this is these are things that are very
rare you know my whole family
say
thank you
this connection
between me and david
i
i never had mama like this with my own
father
wow
and kobe admits that the last thing he
wants to do at this point is betray
emily's dad's trust
so he's tempted to tell him that emily's
pregnant again
and a part of me wanted him to
i was thinking don't mess up your
relationship with mr david you and emily
made him a promise that you broke but
one thing's for for sure
you better not get pregnant now be
honest about it it's something he will
appreciate
but then kobe made a good point if i
tell david now i might betray her trust
true he and emily agreed to keep it a
secret until after the wedding and he's
marrying her not her dad so her trust
comes first
when it comes to the wedding ceremony
everything went over smooth
emily and kobe i now pronounce you
husband and wife you mean i'll kiss your
bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she's so beautiful i love her i'll even
marry her even in my next life oh
kiss me that was so cute
kobe was beaming during the reception
and dancing away you can tell that's
what he's used to
wedding ceremonies where they get down
it's a dance party now that the wedding
is over
is it time to tell the family you're a
secret
no
yeah
it's just the perfect time this is
something today this is something i've
been waiting
you know i've had this it's really heavy
on me i can continue living in your
father's house looking at it she just
relaxed it's not like you're fine
looking at him
did she just say quit looking at him
emily
girl
i'm not gonna say too much because we're
about to get into it but based off her
parents reaction to the news
i can see why she felt comfortable
enough to give that response
just looking at him it sounds and you
won't feel bad it sounds easier to you
but i cannot honey please i just hope
you can understand me and we agreed on
after the wedding
like maybe the next day i'm gonna tell
him
kobe is like uh-uh my respect is on the
line
put some respect on my name i don't know
if it was the next day or what but
eventually emily came around and she and
kobe told her parents over dinner i want
to tell you guys
emily's right now
no
are you serious oh yeah
kobe definitely wanted to tell you
before
but i was like no
oh god
well how far along are you and what's
the what's the deal i mean 10 weeks
jesus
i'll be honest i was underwhelmed
by emily's parents reaction
a part of me expected more
no yelling
i know raising voices is not the most
effective way to communicate
but still
no wonder she didn't seriously try not
to get pregnant again it was a shock
the best thing for them would have been
to get established you know
we wanted them to be in their own home
and
she knew that emily's dad said he had
plans to retire in the next year or so
and travel with his wife
but that's something he can't do now
you're not gonna be able to work you
can't work
seeing their reactions like my fears of
disappointing them are kind of coming
true i think emily she feels very secure
here i mean
maybe we were
we've been too easy on them uh
yeah this is a big deal
[Music]
oh no
oh no it's right
[Music]
oh my god all right
i always wonder if emily's dad would
react this way if the cameras weren't
around
i think he would but either way
the way he holds his composure is
impressive
especially when the money is coming out
of his pocket this is stressing the crap
out of me y'all know stressing over
money can bring the worst out of people
i'm gonna make sure that i'm the man
that i told david that i am and i'm
going to be able to provide for my
family
kobe says he's going to be a man of his
word and handle his business
i wish him the best in that all i know
is that he and emily are beyond lucky to
have the support that they have
beyond
that being said
i hope we get to see the baby at the
tell-all
i'm just saying
assalamualaikum everyone
i will be reciting sora and nabez today
all right let's touch on shaden balao's
wedding that they had at their house
[Music]
daughter's voice sounds beautiful as
shadow walks down the aisle to him
looking like a queen
she's your
queen
[Music]
and these two say i do
that these two now
have tied the knot
eyes married now
ever since she's come to america she's
always been like really timed um and my
dad has been like more happy
yeah i definitely seen that my dad has
been more happy
i feel like she's a great addition to
the new household after the ceremony
below presents sheidle with a gift
it actually has more sentimental and my
first thought after he said sentimental
was oh no
not another prank
but thankfully he and his sister left
the jokes aside for the wedding day
this was something that my father gave
my mother
and
it's in latin
in english that says i will never give
up on you
and on the back it says and you would
never give up on me
[Applause]
the moment i got off the plane i didn't
think i would have made it here like in
the airport yeah in that truck
nah there was definitely a lot of
ups and downs for sure you know um
but i'm the type of person though that i
i'm i'm not a quitter so
i think if this wouldn't have worked it
would have been
her giving up versus me giving up
you see that's not fair he always says
the things that make me look bad hey
they say walking down that aisle does
not fix your problems
that's proof
in side note something i didn't notice
is that balau's ex-wife not only am i
his ex i'm his friend too was not fair
i'm not sure if it's due to religious
customs or maybe shaida preferred not to
have her there or maybe she didn't want
to be there
who knows
but it's something i did catch and i
wanted to mention
alright back to the celebration
it's time to get the party started
hey dj
hit it
um
forgive me i have to throw that in there
for shadow's sister i feel pretty
wedding after we're going to finish
married are going to perform um kanye
west school digger
it's all love it's all love we are going
to retreat
love you guys
congrats shaida and bilal
i'm excited to see what the future holds
for them okay let's move on to jabrie
and miona's wedding
four weddings this episode it's a lot to
cover but i'll try to make this one
quick
[Music]
can i get your numbers
that's how you got me
wow
jabria miona ceremony is in the desert
in joshua tree california
miona was set on not getting married in
jabri's home state of south dakota so
somehow they managed to get the money
that jabrie kept telling me they didn't
have to have the wedding in cali i
compromised on beach wedding but i'm not
willing to compromise on some details
that i really wanted like i always
imagined to have an arch behind me when
we having the ceremony i want those
pictures next to darts i want flowers on
the arch i mean it gives that symmetry
to the photo and without it it wouldn't
be so special to be honest there were
moments this episode where miona had me
thinking that the pictures were more
important to her than the actual
ceremony
but it's her wedding day whatever makes
you happy girl
i want to have those photos because i
want to send them to my parents who are
not going to be there and also for me
for the memory it's also really
important
when it comes to jabrie's parents they
aren't attending the wedding because
they don't think he's ready to get
married
and his mom doesn't seem to be a huge
fan of miona but she sent her well
wishes over the phone for the ceremony
they end up only having two guests
jabrie's super cool grandma who is
officiating the wedding and our friend
igor
who was hours late because he's driving
this arch that miona was so pressed to
have from la to the desert which is
about two plus hours away
always traffic always traffic move your
head around a little bit
grandma
i'm worried about this arch i don't know
where igor is at you know what the
ceremony
for me
is the important part
what
we have the sky
i know and the desert as an arch i know
you know it's we can't delay the
ceremony the sun is not gonna wait for
us
finally igor shows up with this arch
when the heart showed up it was just
like two sticks and i'm like that's the
arch like that but then i'm you know i'm
not gonna say that
and although the arch doesn't look like
much when they set it up next to me on
his dress and jabri's look with the
desert behind them i get the vision it
looks great
once the ceremony starts jabri and miona
walked down the aisle to a country song
he wrote for her that she's never heard
before
and it's a good song
i wrote a song called a thousand miles
for myono which is a country song which
is a genre that i've never done before
as a testament to how far we've been and
how far we're gonna go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reacts in a beautiful way to the song
just like a supportive wifey would that
was an amazing song
and they say i do
i pronounce you
married
you may now kiss
as husband and wife
[Music]
oh congrats
all right last but not least similar to
even muhammad this is another wedding i
didn't see happening between thyes and
patrick at one point her dad was totally
against her marrying patrick
and because she's a daddy's girl i was
sure she was gonna go back home to
brazil
but her dad eventually came around after
patrick promised him he will take care
of his daughter
and now hopefully these two will have
their happily ever after
just looking at daise i'm just blown
away she's just so beautiful
and
it just reminds me of that first time i
saw her in brazil
and literally
i knew
i think i knew at that point like my
entire life was about to change
i went from being divorced and not
knowing if i'd find someone again
oh anymore
i guess like for it to come true
that's
that's really emotional
dreams come true
and thyes looks gorgeous
simply elegant
but still i can't get over the gucci
down officiant
from head to toe
okay brother
when it comes to that wedding he stole
the show for me i now pronounce you man
and wife
you may kiss the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
yay
once again congratulations to all the
couples now you have to tell me how do
you feel about the season overall on a
scale from 1 to 10.
i'mma go with a six
i say a six because it was refreshing
not to have all the shenanigans
but that's also the same reason why i
give it a six because
i ended up missing the shenanigans i
know i shouldn't want people to be out
here acting all wild but
it was a huge adjustment going from
talking about gino and his hat to all
the deep and meaningful conversations
we've had about issues everyday couples
face which i enjoyed y'all know that's
my jam
but it was an adjustment
all right 90 day fans fam the tell-all
is next week
and it looks like drama
shaida
since shahida first came out here you
have not looked at her yeah
why have you not even looked in her
direction
you need to stop third-wheeling bro i
was having a conversation with him but
then you opened your mouth you all in a
business like this your brother are you
still living at home talking about come
on sparkles
we'll go upstairs but i don't want just
do it up there i'm gonna knock him out
if you bring him up there no you're not
if you're gonna bring it bro you gotta
take it you're gonna be the one taking a
lot i'm not scared bro
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all i will see you next
time
[Music]